now tonight violent crime is exploding
in chicago as many big blue states and
cities murders go totally unsolved our
friend john walsh will join us with a
full investigation tonight and prince
harry you know britain's most entitled
most insufferable celebrity along with
his wife has now chosen to reside
full-time in the u.s he wants a quiet
life out of the public eye
but he just announced our country during
a speech at the united nations we're
going to ask piers morgan why the good
prince is living in a country
that uh brings him so much shame piers
by the way we'll send them right back
home to you he'll join us in a bit first
tonight the sky is falling yet again
according to democrats the earth's
imminent destruction is now because of
climate change they really mean it this
time now naturally the only way to save
humanity is to give them more power so
today your president joe biden aborted
boarded air force one
and for a short well high carbon
footprint flight to massachusetts and
then went for a ride in a giant fleet of
suvs gas guzzling suvs specifically
shipped from washington d.c and then
travel to a dust covered lot filled with
diesel-powered
excavators where an italian company
plans to manufacture underwater cables
for wind turbines at some point in the
future now as someone on twitter put it
quote nothing screams reassurance like
the president of the united states
speaking live from an abandoned lot next
door to a strip club near the airport
biden was there to tout america's great
transition to clean energy transition
key word and preview his uh big upcoming
executive orders on climate change joe
bastardi will join us on this in a
little bit but instead he accidentally
told everyone that he has cancer which
we didn't know take a look
the little school i went to holy rosary
grade school
and because it was a four-lane highway
that was accessible
my mother drove us and rather than us be
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer that's why
i and so many others have cancer turns
out joe biden doesn't have cancer
the worst walk back perhaps ever the
white house claiming that joe was
referring to the removal of a
non-melanoma non-life-threatening spot
on his skin which according to the white
house physician was caused by 78 years
in the sun not oil as he claims falling
from the sky in delaware what he was
talking about nobody knows it's not the
first time biden's white house has been
forced to issue an embarrassing
correction following a speech at joe
biden you might remember that a year ago
they walked back as claimed that the
last five fed chairs
two of which are dead support his
spending plans last october they walked
back his vow to call up the national
guard to resolve the supply chain crisis
in january they had to walk back biden's
pledge to look uh the other way if
vladimir putin's invasion into ukraine
was only a minor incursion in march they
walked back his call for regime change
in russia and has vowed a responding
kind to a chemical weapons attack in may
they had to walk back biden's pledge to
go to war with china over taiwan in july
the white house pretended that joe meant
to read the speaking cues and the
teleprompter
repeat the line which as you know has
not now gone viral kind of like let's go
brandon and we could go on and on but
let's get back to the looming
apocalypse now or as mayor p put it
we're running out of time our days are
numbered the end is near
well the end is near let's just throw
one hell of a big party on the way out
that's my idea take a look
nobody thinks that you can make this
change overnight but also i think
there's a clear understanding that when
it comes to the climate we're running
out of time the the science is
unambiguous in terms of the
level of threat in terms of the lives
and livelihoods
that america and the world
stand to lose if we don't accelerate our
action
right this manufactured crisis is of
course a pretense for their giant
socialist power grab that's what new
green dealism is all about you give up
your rights for empty promises you empty
out your wallets for less freedom in
exchange for what they say is government
paid housing guaranteed government
salary guaranteed government job
guaranteed government health care
guaranteed government healthy food
guaranteed government paid vacation
guaranteed government paid cleaner
greener planet
you might have noticed democrats are
calling this a transition we are in the
middle of a transition we're
transitioning transitioning
transitioning what are we transitioning
to what is the alternative to oil gas
and coal okay renewables what renewables
take a look
just 15 years ago america generated more
than half its electricity from coal
coal-fired plants today that's down to
20 percent
because there's a big transition
happening this is what a transition
looks like right this is exactly the
challenge that we're living through to
make sure that the american consumer has
what it needs to grow to grow our
economy and the global economy but not
take steps and endanger the climate
work that we're trying to do to make
sure that we're on a better footing to
accelerate the transition we all have to
be able to reduce the emissions we have
to accelerate the transition this clean
energy transition
could be the piste project
of our time and when it comes to the gas
crisis
we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that god willing
when it's over we'll be stronger and the
world will be stronger
now the only transition is away from
energy independence to energy dependence
on russia iran saudi arabia opec and
venezuela countries that hate our guts
he wants to make them rich again and us
poor again and us dependent again and
compromise on national security in the
meantime now this so-called transition
did you get the word of the day
transition will not make life better on
the planet it won't make the planet any
cleaner in fact for the foreseeable
future meaning at least the next couple
of decades it is logistically and
economically impossible to transition to
their renewable sources of energy the
technology is not up to speed to begin
with and yesterday the genius mayor pete
transportation secretary known for
filling potholes about out in south bend
indiana said he liked the pain that it's
causing you the american people the pain
it's causing is good take a look the
more pain we are all experiencing from
the high price price of gas the more
benefit there is for those who can
access electric vehicles
the more pain the more benefit so while
that genius mayor pete is applauding
your pain joe biden continues to
restrict our domestic production of oil
and gas filling the void by importing
energy from heavy polluters in the
middle east south america and anywhere
else but here of course this great
transition
it's not about saving the planet if the
earth is in such danger why doesn't the
biden administration give up their
massive fleet they have
924 jets for an and helicopters that
cost you the taxpayer nearly a billion
dollars every year you pay for it you
pay for the jet fuel you pay for that
big fat carbon footprint now in reality
this transition isn't about the planet
instead it's all backdoor socialism
democrats in theory rule in perpetuity
one big problem as it stands now almost
no one supports joe biden or his fellow
uh democrats but more pain it's better
for their agenda now they're
historically unpopular brand new
quinnipiac poll out today biden's
approval rating dropped to another
all-time low only 31 approval among
independents it's even lower at 23
and get this according to the same poll
joe's approval among hispanic americans
is even lower 19 now a majority of
african-americans polled they don't want
joe to run for a second term keep in
mind democrats cannot win a nationwide
election without hispanic and
african-american support hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else